[Musique]
l'invité de cette émission c'est eric
duquesne c'est le fondateur des balles
blanches une compétition qui vient en
aide aux enfants hospitalisés et qui
aura lieu le 6 juin prochain au golf du
prieuré
le golf du prieuré justement eh bien
nous en ferons la connaissance avec son
directeur jean françois molina une start
up dans le monde du golf c'est mike
green fille point com qui permet de
réserver des départs en restant chez soi
on a parlé avec un de ses fondateurs
christophe caporal enfin le matériel les
drivers avec raphaël ali près et comme
dans tous les numéros 2 par 78 des
conseils pro
[Musique]
la compétition des balles blanches qui
est organisé pour venir en aide aux
enfants hospitalisés fête cette année
son quinzième anniversaire
on va rencontrer son fondateur eric
ducap éric ducap bonjour bonjour
bataille alors nous sommes ici au golf
du prieuré c'est ici qu'a lieu le 6 juin
prochain la grande compétition des
balles blanches les balles blanches
c'est évidemment des gens qui jouent au
golf mais c'est aussi une compétition
qui est organisée au profit des enfants
hospitalisés
oui tout à fait le 6 juin prochain on
organise avec une soixantaine de
personnalités du monde du sport
spectacle et autres une compétition où
on fait venir une trentaine d'enfants de
différents milieux hospitaliers
hospitalier pardon pour financer
différents projets pour améliorer le
quotidien des enfants hospitalisés
ils viennent ils arrivent sont un petit
peu impressionné on voit pas beaucoup de
sourires et en fait au fur et à mesure
de la journée ils voyent de nombreuses
personnalités et en organise différents
différentes activités pour pour eux et
donc hier partie ils ont la banane et au
premier virage et dorment pas ce qu'ils
sont ils ont passé une journée
extraordinaire le plaisir de participer
quelques éditions des balles blanches
c'est vrai que quand on voit le sourire
des enfants et c'est très beau à voir
c'est la quinzième année à kaka lieu
l'opération des balles blanches
oui tout à fait on a organisé maintenant
au golf du priori ça va faire 13 ans 13
ans et en fait on peut dire que
maintenant les balles blanches et le
golf du prieuré forment une famille
parce que tout personnel de l'est du
golfe du prieuré sont vraiment
extraordinaires ils se donnent vraiment
pour pour ses enfants et ils viennent
travailler gracieusement pour cette
journée les balles mots c'est aussi de
code devenu une institution se dire que
c'est une compétition qui maintenant
extrêmement connu et reconnu et à
laquelle participent beaucoup de
personnalités notamment des grands
sportifs et aussi des beurs des
comédiens des acteurs oui tout à fait il
ya la cause qui fait que ce toutes ces
personnalités se mobilisent
on a aussi des comédiens comme bruno
solo dany boon
on a pas mal de belles de belles
personnalités qui viennent mais c'est
vraiment le coeur qui parle d'abord on
astrid bard qui devient aussi marraine à
côté de laëtitia fourcade et puis jérôme
alonzo qui notent pas un donneur est
d'ailleurs jérôme depuis qu'il a arrêté
ses activités sportives organise dans le
sud le royal balle blanche au royal
mougins au profit des enfants l'année
dernière il a réussi à récolter 24000
euros où on a pu financer pour la
fondation lenval pour les enfants
autistes une courbe ou parce que il en
avait besoin et malheureusement ils
pouvaient pu profiter de la cour parce
qu'elle était en piteuse evans donc tout
ça c'est vraiment pour améliorer le
quotidien et derrière les personnalités
à répondre oui il ya beaucoup évidemment
de gens d'entreprises qui viennent qui
viennent participer
on s'inscrit pour participer à ce grand
bob à 4 donc c'est très joyeux c'est
très festif et on s'inscrit au prix de
l'inscription pour voilà pour venir
jouer au bal blanche
chaque golfeur peut s'inscrire et des
entreprises prennent x x place après il
ya des partenariats également où les là
ça rentre comme sponsoring et puis en
fait ils font un gros don au niveau de
l'association où nous on puisse
justement financer des beaux projets et
vous le disiez tout à l'heure c'est ça
qui est formidable parce que ça et cv il
ya ya ya cette grande de compétition du
6 juin mais vous parlez de d'alonso qui
fait ça 4 mougins il ya une composition
evreux il ya plein de gens qui ont
participé qu'il faut aussi des choses
pour pour les enfants tout à fait là par
exemple comme vous venez de le dire
nous avons une compétition aussi qui est
s'organise à evreux qui s'appelle à pas
de loup ou l'année dernière et ils ont
eu
ils ont eu la gentillesse de nous faire
un don suite à cet événement 10000 euros
où on a financé un projet sur la région
d'evreux on essaye que chaque
compétition selon la région où s'est
organisée que le don puisse rester pour
financer un projet local
alors quand cette journée il ya aussi
vos copains qui arrivent et quand je
parle de vos copains c'est ce qui saute
à l'elysée parce que vous avez longtemps
travaillé à l'elysée oui tout à fait en
fait avec guillaume gomez on a on est on
est cofondateur de la de l'association
les cuisiniers de la république
française qui génère tout en fait tous
les cuisiniers français qui travaillent
pour l'état français partout dans le
monde et ils se mobilisent pour nous
apporter lors leur soutien et il
organise enfin yves fabricant fait près
de 1000 1200 repas pour cette journée et
le soin ont fini autour d'un barbecue
géant avec des côtes de boeuf etc et
tout ça c'est un partenariat et ça coûte
rien à l'association alors du fait de
votre présence à l'elysée pendant 15 ans
il y aussi le parrainage de cette
journée qui a été longtemps le fait des
premières dames de l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est un peu plus compliqué il n'a plu
oui c'est ça disons qu'en fait cette
démarche c'était surtout pour montrer le
sérieux de l'association est vraiment
démontré que en fait on peut nous faire
confiance pour des projets nous on est
une association où on fonctionne à peu
près qu'à 20% de de frais de
fonctionnement
donc après tout le reste est réinjecté
pour les projets des enfants quoi en
fait c'est le but je vois pas pourquoi
je j'utiliserai 80 % de frais de
fonctionnement et 20% pour les enfants
le but c'est vraiment pour les enfants
alors on va il ya une petite tradition
pour cette émission c'est que l'invité
on lui fait taper quelques balles
et puis on va soumettre votre swing
impro un signe d'une sorte de leçon
gratuite vous êtes d'accord
c'est une leçon gratuite ça va aller
mais
surtout vous regardez pas les images au
regard d un peu merci beaucoup eric du
club
pour examiner peut être corrigé le swing
de notre invité éric du cad
on va retrouver notre propre référer au
golf national c'est sébastien russie
vous savez qui tourne toujours quelque
chose à redire sur les swings de nos
invités
bonjour à tous bienvenue en golf
national patrice m'a de nouveau confier
la tâche de naizin swing ce que si ce
sera justement le swing monsieur
duquenne qui est l'organisateur des
balles blanches que je n'ai pas le
plaisir de connaître
du coup j'ai pris le temps de regarder
un petit peu ce qui le faisait on voit
notamment qu'il a tendance à avoir une
phase de clubs qui évoluent en étant
très fermé
je veux montrer ce que je veux dire par
là cercueil de profil
lorsqu'il démarre son swing la tête de
club a tendance à regarder énormément le
sol ici avec un club qui se déplace un
tout petit peu trop dans cette zone à
l'intérieur et qui me donne donc une
phase de club qui est très fermé là ok
alors la descente mais se débrouille
plutôt bien qu'il a du coup tendance à
bloquer un petit peu les mains
légèrement dans la frappe
et avec cette tendance deux faces faire
mais ça reste de nous donner du push
c'est à dire une balle qui va démarrer à
droite qui va y rester s'ils bloquent
les mains si l'espace est un club ça
reste de lui donner un look donc une
balle qui va tourner assez excessivement
à gauche à cause de cette phase de club
ce que je peux lui préconisé c'est que
pour améliorer déjà cette chose c'est
simplement de travailler un petit peu
sur la position de sa main droite qui
est beaucoup trop sous le club et celles
qui provoquent justement dans l'armement
cette tendance deux faces fermé il
faudrait simplement qu il repositionne
sa paume nommant un peu plus en relation
avec la face du club
petit exercice très simple il peut très
bien cherché à prendre son grip en
pointant avec son index un objet vers le
sol ce qui va lui obligé à positionner
sa paume de main en relation avec la
face c'est à partir de là il n'a plus
qu'à refermer la gâchette avec le pouce
et l'index simplement ça ça va déjà lui
permettre d'améliorer considérablement
son jeu de golf une deuxième petite
chose on observe une tendance à lover
swing assez marqué c'est à dire qu'il va
trop loin
simplement cette tendance à aller trop
loin et juste lié au fait qu'il devrait
chercher un peu plus de résistance avec
les jambes
simplement car quand il tourne il a
tendance à bouger un peu trop les
hanches latéralement et à s'en servir un
peu trop ce qui pourrait lui permettre
également de prendre plus de distance en
créant plus de résistance ici et à ce
moment là ça lui permet très simplement
couplé avec cette main droite d'avoir
une phase plus square au sommet et de
raccourcir la longueur de son bac fring
afin de l'aider à obtenir plus de
régularité
[Musique]
non ce numéro je vous propose de
découvrir un des plus beaux golfs de
france qui se trouve dans le parc
naturel de vaccins c'est le goff du
prieuré pour en parler je vais rejoindre
son directeur jean françois molina jean
françois molina bonjour bonjour vous
êtes l'heureux directeur du golf de
prioriser heureux directeur parce que
c'est un site et un parcours absolument
magnifique
ça fait combien de temps ça fait une
quinzaine d'années alors cela fera 16
ans ont dû juin que je suis la chance
d'être directeur du lobby priori ce qui
ne nous rajeunit pas tout à fait je vous
l'accord voulu que vous le connaissiez
avant de devenir du directeur il y a de
cela au moins 25 ans j'étais déjà région
parisienne et je m'étais fait un paquet
de temps oui j'étais au web de montgri
fond oui et je m'étais fait un point
d'honneur à faire tous les grands golf
de la région parisienne et j'avais joué
le prieuré deux fois et à l'époque le
directeur était philippe archambault
d'accord un mot sur ce progrès c'est un
vraie prière l1 tout à fait l'origine
c'est comme priori du 12e siècle c'était
des grandes montées et en 1963 en même
temps que tous les terrains il a été
acquis pour nous ça mouille et de
l'époque et en 1965 nous avons ouvert
les deux 18 trous
la piscine et le prieuré rénover tout en
même temps avec les tennis et les clubs
des enfants et à saintes 1 4965
construction d'une offre de l'architecte
c'est cliff et drake autres y sont
grandes grand architecte te fais de golf
c'est un des grands grand golf de la
région parisienne est évidemment un des
grands groupes français
nous avons eu la chance effectivement
d'avoir cinq étoiles ce magazine d'une
famille coût 12 secondes ouais donc cinq
étoiles c'est sympathique maintenant il
faut tenir et notre président monsieur
cormier
les membres du comité nous et nos
membres nous voulons bien évidemment
aller vers le haut et donc nous essayons
de faire en sorte d'y arriver est de
mettre tout en oeuvre pour que l'on soit
un golf bien évidemment de renan est
aussi que nos membres sont contents d'y
jouer
on a l'impression qu'on s'engueule comme
ça disait dans un lieu aussi idyllique
au caire qu'à laisser les choses en
l'état depuis tout va bien c'est pas
tout à fait ça quand même
alors ça me plaît comme une question
puisque je pense qu'il faudrait que l'on
conserve l'étiquette du golf puisque
l'étiquette c'est vrai que c'est une
tenue vestimentaire et c'est un
comportement et on fait en sorte de le
conserver mais aussi on s'oriente vers
l'avenir
il est vers le futur à savoir de faire
aimer le golfe à un plus grand nombre
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous on
est une école de golf qui fonctionne
bien nos pros et puis tout ce qui s'en
occupe
faire en sorte que ça se passait bien et
du coup nous faisons des événementiels
en semaine pour des grandes sociétés et
grâce à ces événements si un levier pour
nous ce vecteur de communication
vous le disiez il ya en effet des
membres et des gens qui viennent au
green fille combien de membres au
prieuré
alors nous avons 5 125 adultes permanent
qui peuvent donc jouer le week-end et
jours fériés
quand nous avons 180 enfants et ensuite
nous avons des membres souligné qu'il ne
joue que je mène nous avons des
bridgeurs et du membre piscine puisque
nous respectons nos membres fondateurs
est arrivé à un certain âge bien le golf
mais l'horizon n'est plus possible donc
ils viennent juste pour déjeuner ou pour
jouer au bridge dans ce cadre il dit
cela il ya deux grands parcours ici le
parc ont avancé par rouge et bleu assez
y est et ouest il fait et ils sont assez
semblables est assez différent quand
même alors tout à fait nous avons la
chance d'avoir le parcours est qui est
assez vallonné et qui a un paysage un
petit peu différent du parcours ouest
il est plus court mais beaucoup plus
technique et des greens qui ont
sacré caractère et ensuite nous avons le
parcours ouest qui lui est difficile je
pense de par sa longueur donc c'est
toujours été le parcours du championnat
et les greens sont plus simples à petit
donc un petit peu toutes les populations
peuvent les retrouver
il ya aussi on peut venir un joueur au
graphique plutôt en semaine c'est ça
alors voilà les greens fille sont bien
évidemment elle est bienvenue en semaine
et nous réservons le week-end pour nos
membres et le terme de green fille je
préfère moi
pour rebaptiser ce terme un membre d'un
jour ainsi nous devons de les accueillir
comme un membre et on espère qu'un jour
ils le deviendront
l'un des atouts de ce golf et des
membres des gens qui sont bons mais ici
c'est que ils peuvent jouer n'importe
quand quand ils veulent enfin alors ne
pas y ait pas de problème tout à fait en
respectant le système de réservation que
nous avons mis au point nos membres
n'ont jamais eu un refus de départ on se
doit de leur domaine des ports à partir
du moment où ils sont présentés l'heure
et demie après si on devait projeter un
peu comme ça qu'est ce qui va se passer
dans les quatre cinq ou dix années qui
viennent comment vous voyez l'évolution
des gaules du prieuré
le golf du prieuré est capable
d'accueillir des événements de renom
ouais on aimerait notre président a
convié
membre du comité et moi même recevoir un
événement de prestige pour le recevoir
il faut quand même commencer à mettre
enfin continuer à travailler sur nos
grilles nano bunker hill au départ nous
avons des chantiers
cette année d'avoir attaqué le chantier
des départs et des bunkers pour monter
toujours le niqab en gamme nous allons
recevoir une compétition nationale en
2018 je me dire le nom encore puisque
cette matrice à tuer mais une belle
compétition et ensuite on aimerait
recevoir une compétition du circuit
mais pour ce faire il faut avoir un
nombre de stands sont conséquents et
monter en gamme encore un petit peu donc
c'est notre objectif à 3 4 ans donc ça
ça va être voilà le boulot des trois
quatre ans qui viennent
merci infiniment gens face aux verts et
encore bravo pour votre travail vous
vous habitez par là vous en profitez
j'ai la chance d'habiter sur le site
près de la science un oui donnera peut
être place pour rien au monde je pense
tout à fait ouverte et beaucoup en
france à vous entendre vous et merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]
en compagnie de christophe caporal qui
est un des fondateurs de la société
albatros qui a mis au point
l'application my jeune fille point com
qui permet aux golfeurs de réserver leur
parcours alors en quoi consiste cette
application est pourquoi vous l'avez
créé mais alors on a créé cette société
il ya cinq ans et en fait l'idée était
simple c'était de faciliter la vie des
golfeurs en proposant des nouveaux
services de réservation en ligne en
temps réel à partir de smartphones ou
d'ordinateur vraiment et l'idée c'était
dans trois clics de pouvoir réserver son
gré une fille vous allez sur le site
internet et vous avez juste à vous
enregistrez c'est complètement gratuit
vous pouvez aller sur la pile
l'application c'est pareil et donc vous
devenez membre d'umma de magritte si.com
puis après ben vous avez juste à acheter
vous pouvez même déposer votre carte
bleue son problème et en trois clics ou
réservés le golfeur bas utilisent déjà
son smartphone pour réserver son billet
de train pour réserver à son restaurant
pas pourquoi pas son golf et c'est venu
tout naturellement et maintenant quand
on fait ça depuis cinq ans être ça
connaît vraiment un succès grandissant
alors la société est à croissy sur seine
dans les yvelines
vous êtes vous êtes combien de combien
de personnes travaillent c'est vous
aujourd'hui une dizaine de personnes
quand la société a été fondée il ya cinq
ans vous étiez peu nombreux le suppose
et il fallait être pris au sérieux et
évidemment pas par les golfs que vous
débarquiez mais c'est vrai que c'est
toute une aventure vous partez d'une
feuille blanche
après vous associer avec un ami
généralement et puis vous relever les
manches et puis vous allez combattre
gauche par golfe au début on vous prend
pas au sérieux et à la fin un petit à
petit les gens ce qu'on vous suive et
aujourd'hui on est on a atteint le seuil
des 200 golf donc si vous voulez par
rapport à 6 ans gosses c'est déjà une
bonne bonne taille et chaque jour chaque
jour est une nouvelle conquête
donc on peut le dire au directeur de
golf qui n'ait pas peur comme c'est pas
comme certains sites qui qui loue des
hôtels gif aux pressions sur les hôtels
pour qu'ils puissent les prix depuis le
début on a pensé cette solution là pour
les exploitants de golf donc c'est bien
eux qui fixent les prix est d'ailleurs à
chaque fois qu'une réservation sur le
green fille sont pré payées à l'avancé
donc tout a été fait si vous voulez pour
aider les exploitants et de forme et
finalement un nouveau circuit de
distribution pour eux original
le golfeur va voir le planning en entier
enfin ce qui est présenté est vraiment
le planning que voix l'exploitant et
donc après les créneaux horaires et
tarifs les directeurs en fonction de la
journée du temps la période la saison va
fa va faire on faire un tarif est donc à
ce moment là chacun y trouve son intérêt
vous allez pas mettre au chômage des
gens qui sont à l'accueil dans les golfs
avec votre application surtout pas parce
qu'au contraire on est très
complémentaires ont fait gagner beaucoup
beaucoup de temps à google ça leur
permet justement d'alors de pouvoir
faire des meilleurs services par exemple
de développer des activités
additionnelles comme la boutique vous
des activités de restauration par
exemple alors qu'avant ils n'avaient
jamais le temps de le faire parce que
c'est le téléphone sonnait tout le temps
alors on a parlé du passé l'avenir
maintenant le développement
c'est quoi ces deux dalles et défricher
d'autres sports ou de les convaincre
encore plus de 2 de golf
oui on s'y met en fait il ya déjà
aujourd'hui des des exploitations qui
gère des tennis et des golfs et ils nous
ont demandés forcément d'aller vers le
tennis est donc là on est en train
d'équiper des gosses justement avec nos
solutions pour le tennis l'avenir
clairement ça va être de proposer nous
utilisateurs de pouvoir voyager
donc on a commencé à ouvrir d'autres
pays on a ouvert en belgique en suisse
en allemagne en autriche et dans le
coran c'est simple parce que vous avez
la même appli il est l'appli est
universel et donc quel que soit le pays
ou visitez bas vous avez le toujours ce
principe de géolocalisation puis vous
réservez votre grille de fille en temps
réel de la même façon merci beaucoup
questeur caporal et longue vie donc
albatros et à mike green fields québec
qui veut évidemment change un peu la vie
d'aider des golfeurs bravo et merci
[Musique]
on va parler driver dans d'autres
séquences matériel et pour en parler on
va retrouver le responsable du fis tic
du golf national
raphaël halipré bonjour donc aujourd'hui
nous allons parler des drivers club qui
déchaîne les passions dans les sacs des
golfeurs donc déjà en préambule je
voudrais dire que driver est devenu
maintenant un club facile à jouer de par
son volume de tête
il représente vous l'impact assez large
donc même un joueur de niveau débutant
ou en progression peugeot aucun driver
maintenant comment choisir son driver
sur le marché aujourd'hui différentes
marques proposent beaucoup de choses ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ils étaient deux clubs
sont toutes très performant donc le
manche le char tu vas devenir quelque
chose de prépondérant pourquoi pas ce
qu'on va essayer de trouver une
flexibilité qui correspond à la vitesse
du joueur un point d'inflexion également
qui permet un décollage spécifique donc
pour ça on va utiliser des outils comme
le trachman le trac manettes un radar en
fait qui va filmer votre balle et nous
permettre avec des données très précises
de connaître votre vitesse de clubs
votre vitesse de balle angle de
décollage et avec ça on va pouvoir
optimiser votre jeu très important
chose importante à comprendre également
souvent chez les golfeurs on a des lofts
notre langue du club assez fermé pensons
aller loin avec une balle basse alors
que c'est souvent le contraire il faut
que la balle puisse monter assez haut
pour faire une grande courbe et aller le
plus loin possible et rouler le plus
possible donc pour ça je conseille
vivement de se rendre au centre keating
avec des analyses de deux balles pour
pouvoir optimiser votre décollage la
longueur et la route de la balle
[Musique]
se retrouve dans l'astuce du champion
avec karine hicheur notre invité trois
solheim cup quand même et qui va nous
aider à dénouer un petit coup vraiment
très particulier mon karine j'ai loupé
le green de quelques mètres
l'herbe est magnifique un peu partout
autour de ce green est là justement je
retrouve ma balle dans un mauvais l'aïe
il ya quasiment pas d'herbe dessous on
est à moitié dans un niveau
qu'est ce que tu me conseilles donc dans
ce cas là quand la balle et pas
forcément bien lie et ce qu'on appelle
la y est c'est qu'elle repose sur de
l'herbe à ses hôtes
et bien porté moi ce que je préconise
c'est d'oublier le faire un sandwich ou
même un club plus fermé parce que là
c'est vraiment vraiment très difficile
et je prends des hybrides rescue ça peut
très bien être aussi un bois de parcours
en bois 5 ou 1 mois 3 et je vais la
jouer comme un pote
ce qui va permettre à la balle de rouler
et puis
je ne pourrai
normalement pas faire ni de gratte ni de
top ce qui est le risque dans cette
situation parce que c'est c'est le coup
en général qui sort le plus souvent
alors je met mon ma balle vraiment sur
le pied droit
même à la limite extérieur du pied droit
pour vraiment la prendre en premier et
je vais grippe est évidemment très court
sur les grippes parce que j'ai un rescue
donc il faut que je sois quand même
assez proche de la balle le poids sur la
jambe gauche
dumas ligne évidemment et là j'ai
effectué un mouvement de potter j'essaye
pas de la soulever j'essaye pas de la
punch et je fais juste un mouvement
potter et la grande difficulté ici c'est
de mettre le bon dosage pour avoir la
bonne vitesse sur le green
dans ce cas de figure votre balle sera
toujours sur le green plus ou moins près
du drapeau évidemment il faut
s'entraîner parce que ça demande pas mal
de pratique avant de maîtriser ce coup
là mais en tout cas ça sera le moyen le
plus sûr de faire soit chipote soit
cheap de potes mais pas pire merci de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite pour le nouveau numéro 2 par 78
[Musique]